do you ever like leave your phone at
home by accident forget it I don't never
leave the phone at home I got a wife
can't do that buddy what's up GQ it's
your boy out set and these are the 10
things that I cannot live
without my babies right here you see
these these right here these some 85s
you ain't got these and then the
condition I got them in is just so
perfect and beautiful the thing why I
love these shoes is they don't even got
a match you can just throw these on cuz
it's just it's a 85s what somebody going
to say to you
how many ones you got over like 200
probably for sure how many 85s I got I
probably got like I got the black toes I
got these I got three pair of these
actually I got one in a size nine and
I'm and I'm a N9 and half 10 but they
were so clean I just had to get them so
I probably got like four pair five pair
I ain't never caught nothing off of eBay
I be scared a little bit too I ain't
going to get caught for nothing I don't
got everything I want I just want
everything you know what I've been
looking for though me and my boy A-Rod
been looking for the all the old barys
can't find them can't find them at all
and I like I like 15 so you got to
really know what you doing you like the
15s who you think your collection Riv PJ
Tucker for show Fat Joe Fat Joe is a
maniac and then mayor may had like some
sede orange threes I ain't going to lie
l yti nasty too though he get Wicked
with it cuz he go old school Nike like
that everybody don't know nothing about
so current rap is nobody with
you
no my next
essential the petw chrs see the reason
why I love these is cuz I've been on it
see what I'm saying like I've been on it
I like to see the growth of when I wear
something and then I see it everywhere
these pants right here my pair be one of
one so I get mine custom so a they not
in the market and then like if you ever
see the resale value on Chrome it be
like 20 30,000 for for the jeans so it's
like can't really go in the store and
buy them out the store so it's not
accessible for everybody I did a mic
look for M live Miami and I got a custom
from chromart and so that's my people so
you got to have the chromes and
everybody don't got these you got to
watch them crosses too cuz them boys be
C see the crosses don't be together them
crosses peeling up and they be a certain
Shadee they be having cap chome heart
you ain't tricking me I don't wear a Mir
nothing against michir shout out to him
you a great designer but I don't wear
mic mirrors I was wearing those in 2017
in bad and boie video you can go check
the receipts I just be trying to be
ahead of the curve a lot of times with
things that I do mannequin challenge a
lot of these cats be looking like
mannequins but I'm going to stay in my
Lane I like pieces that's all I say I
just like pieces it's a piece because
it's not what everybody else is you
can't everybody can't get to it and it's
like understanding the brand and what
you love and like about the brand stay
away from what everybody else got all
right so the gloves right it's always a
good accessory like for a fit or like
especially when I'm performing I always
like to have glove on these right here
of course inspired by Mike I'm just
falling to the character of like making
myself better as a solo act and taking
it there like creative creatively wise
and making it about me first and
foremost it's my favorite artist of all
time got to tatted on me twice I got
like a baby picture like when we were so
broke we had like books on the TV like
to hold the TV up and I'm like standing
in front of that with a button
unbuttoned shirt with glove on like when
I'm probably like five or six or
something like that he just always with
my favorite artist I just appreciated
the art he put into hisself it's like he
don't care about nothing else he's just
making himself better and it's kind of
like my story of how I feel and like his
album was off the wall my album name is
set it off I'm standing in character for
my album I ain't going to talk too much
on it but I got these customade these
right here is Chrome custom these is
crazy one one can't get these I be
liking a lot of gloves it be like worker
gloves like with the little Knuckles on
it or like this is a this a worker glove
but it look like crazy it just be a good
accessory for the outfit like if I throw
these gloves on right now it's going to
look good with what I got on and if I
need to knock somebody out I'm just
playing see what I'm saying the right
here just look hard just a good
accessory my next essential will have to
be glasses let me put these on show you
how good I look with them
on I like the mysterious you not seeing
my eyes that's why I always get LS I do
like like glasses here and there it
depend on the outfit for that but for
the most part I like dark glasses it's
just it's a need 24 hours I'm in the
club with the glasses on in the
interview glasses on in the bathroom
glasses on I like older Versace glasses
those are the always the best cuz I get
that from watching masterpie a long time
and go like one the guys who influen me
prodact got these specific glasses I
love I keep wearing them they got like
the Octavian side they just fit my face
so perfect I like slim glasses I don't
really like the big wide lens glasses
cuz that ain't it don't be fit my face I
lose glasses all the time and sometime I
be mad cuz sometimes you can't find them
like the products they didn't they
didn't restock those for like a month
and a half two months so I would just
without them I always do glasses though
it's just going to
happen so my next essential bring the
treasure chest out this ain't all up but
this the jewelry it's my jewelry case
turn that around for you I'm big on my
Jesus Pieces it's the rose go with the
big Emerald sets in the head you got to
catch that right there shout out to my
Jeweler Elliott the best jeweler in the
game you see see how he put the pink
stones with the blue stones and the head
cross like he be making fine jewelry and
it just stand out like like this piece
right here like like why do you got the
yellow flower sets in there with the
pink and the blue like a different chain
and just hit like just hit different you
going to get your money worth this is
early Elliott that's Ric FL woo this the
Bando piece right here you know big doll
and it stand up see this what Ellie do
he put screws in the back the details he
got spray paint in the house they say
Migo gang back cuz this the B this the
Bando house right here then look at this
piece right here this the Gold version
instead of it being all bust down it's
like gold with the diamond and bells
this this is something Tiffany would
make how they the style that they would
go not so bust down and just the pair
shapes inside of the flowers is heavy
you can you can hear it so like even
while I'm talking right now my chains
ain't clacking cuz like he put the heavy
weight into it and of course we got the
the three-headed monster me gang for
life that's just what it is the end of
the day he put the emeralds you put our
face our actual faces we got diamonds in
our glasses earrings we got chains on
the chain it's just disrespectful this
cost a lot of money if I'm going to
spend my money I want my money to be
sacred and then he then also Elliot
teach you about the jewy so he going to
teach you he going to give you the game
on what the diamonds is and what to look
out for even when you shopping outside
of him that's why I F him like I could
call him and be like hey he won't talk
you out of it and be like no come to
mind he'll be like get this one don't
get that other one that other one don't
look like it's woo woo woo or like the
cut on it or how they promp or the
setting of The Diamonds ain't really
what they saying it is and if you do
that to most other Jewelers they going
to hate and be like n come straight to
me we came in like wearing ring on every
finger when it was just gold before it
was diamonds we had mul mul chains and
then like the length of the chain making
it shorter and more presentable so like
dangling going everywhere we definitely
influen the game the double watches was
a thing in a time you know what I'm
saying we was just flooding it up and
like we having two watches two bus Downs
on but now I switched up my whole thing
I don't even wear bus Downs it's plain
Jane or nothing I want my wife to be
worth something I ain't trying to lose
value in it this boy IET on on the Rocks
yes sir my bad I guess this was on the
Rocks
too my n cental my phone and my
headphones you know the phone I can
never lose this phone cuz it got my
unreleased music in there and a certain
file on the phone that's super important
you know family I could be reached for
my kids I got my brother take on the
back of my screen always reminder that
we do it for him I like the Apple
headphones cuz it's like a fashion
statement too I ain't going to lie like
you can put these on with a fit and it
kind of look good with the fit and also
like you could you can block all the
noise out with these so that's why you
got to have that phone on them
headphones I feel like a lot of people
do the in cuz they also talk see I never
talk on headphones I only listen to my
music and like my mixes and like the
production of it in the headphone cuz I
would want to know like how somebody who
might be working out got some headphones
in it's always always for music for me I
might do a voice memo if like a producer
sent me something in the car and I play
it real quick I might do a voice memo
just to have the reference idea but
other than that it's mly in the studio
though anybody I'm listen to I'm rocking
with my boy TR right now his album Dr
you toia hard Don he tried to album
was hard Pluto he be going crazy th dro
the album was hard yeah same old same
old then I just been really focusing on
my sound and like trying to masterm like
to make sure it's that pressure you know
do you ever like leave your phone at
home by accident forget it I don't never
leave the phone at home I got a wife
can't do that buddy I need to be able to
pick it up I got kids I got too many
import it's too much business to be
handled I never leave my phone you need
that phone the wife for real though
so for my next essential will have to be
my big heres bag where I carry the
essentials in it's so big I can put a
whole outfit shoes I can put my glasses
my gloves everything in and also it's a
army fatigue bag so any outfit I put on
it Go With It black white green purple
Whatever It Go with everything inside of
here got an essential inside the
essential bag B wash ass boy oh I think
it was like 30,000 but it's thing is
with the heres bags all of them going
value so right now it's probably 60,000
or 70,000 on the market they only give
two bags a year to the client no matter
who you are so you got to it's allocated
bags so yeah it's rare if I could catch
it then I'm going to buy it for sure cuz
I know it's a piece and it's also going
to go up in value so I'm not going to
never sell it but it's also it's just
like it's a piece like we was talking
about earlier it's like that's a piece
the bag inside this bag is a piece too
I'mma show you this the Chrome I think
this from like the '90s
if you going to have a bag on it got to
be a piece it has to be a
piece next essential lighter got to have
a lighter and it got my brother take on
it you know my boy love the gas and blow
one every time I light one up it's like
I'm blowing my boy so I mean you got a
big ain't going to never fail you know
what I'm saying but I like this lighter
in specific cuz it's custom and I got
his picture on a lot of Lighters like
this oh yeah I like Gro I like I like
grab a leaf act the leaf and I wrap it
up in the paper too cuz see me I'm a
harsh smoker so I like my blunch to KI
it's more healthy of course the paper
straight paper but I prefer a
Grable my next essential hygiene fellas
you got to be clean I wash my face with
stex cuz I got I got oily skin I hit the
face up with stex I don't wear lotion I
only wear oil cuz I'm smooth like that
you see what I'm saying I got dark
beautiful chocolate skin so I like the
skin to be moisturized and be looking
good so I don't really rock with the
lotion it be kind of too thick for me
personally I do spray deodorant
sometimes to wipe deodorant and be like
all on my clothes I'm not with all that
Aqua for like I said with my skin I
don't play so if I don't have no no oil
I'mma put some aqua for and put some on
right
now then it's skin tight right here so I
get like hair bumps from like shaving my
hair so when I get cut up I got to go
skin tight dissolve and close my pores
up so I be nice and clean and that's it
right there for the
hygiene my next essential wild Clippers
you can never go wrong with the wild
Clippers and me personally I can get it
INR if my hair grow out too long my hair
like be growing curly so I always got to
cut my my beard my facial hair we go old
school my granddaddy used to cut me with
these you see what I'm saying these are
never fair you make sure you clean them
you all them up you take the screw loose
when you need to get up under that blade
keep that F clean and that's how we
coming man I use them probably like 3
Days Every 3 days cuz I don't be want no
inrs or no bumps or so I just go
and chop it off GQ thank you for having
me I might now go get that you dig